في المحطه الاولى لزيارته الى الولايات
المتحده اختار الرئيس الاوكراني هذا
المستشفى في نيويورك حيث يعالج جنود
اوكرانيون اصيبوا في المعارك الاضواء
مسلطه على الذي يشارك حضوريا لاول مره في
اجتماعات الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
منذ الغزو الروسي لبلاده زيلينسكي اجاب عن
سؤال يتعلق بحضوره كلمه وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه المرتقبه امام الجمعيه العامه
لا اعرف كيف ستجري الامور لكن المهم
بالنسبه الينا هو ان يزغي شركائنا لما
سنقوله
واذا ما زال الارهابيين الروس مكان في
الامم المتحده فان هذا السؤال لا يجب ان
يوجه اليه
وانما الى جميع اعضاء الامم المتحده
سؤال مرادف لضغوط الدبلوماسيه على عدد من
دول الجنوب المنفتحه على موسكو والتي
تراهن على حل تفوضي بعد عام ونصف من الغزو
الروسي من بين هذه الدول البرازيل التي لم
تفرض عقوبات ماليه على روسيا على
اجندهنسكي مباحثات مع الرئيس لولاده سيلفا
داخل الامم المتحده ستحاول كياف الاقتراب
ايضا من الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
لاعاده احياء اتفاق توليد الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود قبل اللقاء
المرتقب بين الرئيس الاوكراني والرئيس
الامريكي في البيت الابيض يوم الخميس
المقبل